[Music]
Khloe Kardashian gets real about her sex
life since getting pregnant
whatever you do before pregnant you're
allowed to continue for her apps love
and lust week the reality star answered
romance related questions one fan asked
what do you think of having sex during
pregnancy Khloe did not hold back
sharing her answer on Friday quote in
the beginning sex was the same adding as
I got into my third trimester and
started to get bigger it became harder
to have sex and a little more
uncomfortable and limiting it's just all
like weird what's happening I think it's
just like you're growing a human and
Khloe has been glowing and gorgeous
throughout her pregnancy but she admits
she doesn't always feel that way when
being intimate with her boyfriend
tristan thompson
kuo personally I get uncomfortable and
insecure also you can't move the same so
you kind of feel useless despite how she
feels Koko admits Tristan never makes
her feel bad about her new body and she
does her best to improvise for her men
in the bedroom just me interesting like
we're doing so well
[Music]
you